Michelle karra is amassed over 3 million
subscribers with her unique ability to
take on the world's most demanding
challenges from Marine boot camp to FBI
Academy to training like a Victoria's
Secret supermodel Michelle has
completely lived it all while sharing
her experiences for the entire world to
see today we're diving into the business
of Michelle getting an inside look into
some of the most demanding careers of
the 21st century seeing which careers
make the most amount of money and all of
that starts as soon as you subscribe
did you subscribe Jack no are you gonna
do it yes okay welcome back to the iced
coffee hour my name is Michelle and if I
had to guess I think that the podcast
has made two million dollars oh man no
if I hit by like ten yeah I better be
closer 270
000 exactly today
yeah and here we are and here we are
back at the old Abode I know we're in La
for vidsummit and so we may do and we're
back at our old spot now so uh thank you
so much for being able to make this
happen for coming down here and uh
here's what I found interesting Colin
and Samir called you the most badass
person what was it in the world or what
what is this not in the world
and I have to say I recently watched
your uh Marathon video where you ran 30
miles and I watched a progression
through that and then I went through the
backlog and I've seen your videos before
in the past but I think it was about a
week and a half two weeks ago where when
you posted that video I went through all
the other videos oh God I was I was
really impressed because it looked like
these movie production uh videos that
you're posting on YouTube like joining
the SWAT team the 9-1-1 dispatch and
you've done these incredible careers for
like a week and then documented that
it's incredible thank you yeah thank you
so much thanks for the views you're
welcome how did you get started on that
and you start with BuzzFeed is that
correct yeah so um when I moved to LA I
actually moved out because I was signed
to a professional cycling team for Road
cycling my senior year of college I
somehow won nationals um and so I got
signed and moved to LA and while I was
here here I was also working at BuzzFeed
because
being a female professional athlete is
not a very lucrative thing specifically
in cycling you can't speak for other
sports and so I was literally like
waking up at four training going to work
making you know the crazy BuzzFeed
videos you've seen
um and then after work training again
going to sleep Friday I would leave work
why somewhere in the world Grace come
back it was a pretty wild experience at
the same time so I was growing as an
athlete and also as a video producer
and so it kind of got to this point
where it's like I feel I feel like I
should merge these two loves and so I
left my job at BuzzFeed and started
challenge accepted which is the series I
do on my channel and I kind of said
goodbye to professional cycling because
I felt like I could reach a larger
audience if I took my skill set of
athleticism and everything I learned
from being on a professional team and
applied it to any profession I'm really
curious because you said that you won
nationals there was a time where you
were the best female cycler like
basically in high school a very brief
time cycler cyclists yeah
and on a very specific event the
Criterium under 23. that's interesting
so I did cross country in high school
and I noticed that a lot of the hard
work and effort that I put into
cross-country translates into so many
other facets of my life have you noticed
that your history and cycling
translates to some other growth in your
professional career yeah yeah absolutely
I would say that just like being able to
be regimented waking up early committing
fully to everything I do all of that
comes from that Arena of life I think
there's a big crossover between people
who are good at Fitness and 100
successful in other areas because anyone
who's like really buff or like really
dedicated to their craft of like working
out I've noticed though they tend to be
good in other areas too because of the
same qualities it takes to like go to
the gym do stuff when you don't feel
like it you have to have an opportunity
yeah and an understanding that on the
other side of pain is something greater
yeah and that applies to any form of
Entrepreneurship I think it's also
delayed gratification because if you go
to the gym once you're like why didn't I
get a six-pack then it's like you want
to see the progression over a year and
not necessarily like here's a day or a
week also if you're physically fit you
feel more motivated just in general and
feeling better obviously will translate
to working hard yeah how do you get a
job at BuzzFeed how did that start what
year was this oh my God like was this
that this is like that 14. so like as
much BuzzFeed is like the Heyday like
I'm watching too many of those videos
now I watch all of them so yeah the rise
and fall apart
um
okay and I got an opportunity to
interview and as part of the interview
process you have to say like you check a
box this is you live in Los Angeles no
obviously I checked the box but I didn't
um so when I got the interview I
like the little savings I had and I was
like I'm just gonna buy a round-trip
ticket to La for 24 hours hope I get it
thank God I did
and I moved to LA what's the pay like
when you start at BuzzFeed is it is it
good or I I've heard they maybe don't
pay the most competitive but it's
BuzzFeed so it's like you want to get
your foot in the door well I mean I
think that at that time the connotation
of BuzzFeed was
different than it is now
um and again this was like like you just
mentioned kind of on the rise to Peak I
think the peak viewership was in 2015. I
might have that wrong
um but it was like a really cool place
to work and to learn and as you know
even from your experience working for
Graham and everything you've learned
from that
um you make those sacrifices at the
beginning of your career so it was
definitely like hourly like just barely
above minimum wage definitely make a lot
more as a solo YouTuber than you do and
what was the appeal to BuzzFeed for you
so I am very I'm a very structured
person I work very well when there's a
coach figure in my life and I'd seen a
lot of other YouTubers just sort of you
know I put up a video and then I went
viral and now I have a career out of it
but at that time I felt like there were
very few case studies of a procedural
approach to success on YouTube and
BuzzFeed to me was like a Disney Channel
of YouTube at the time it was an
opportunity to oh I could go can be on a
show there or learn learn the whole
industry and then after my career at
Disney channel is done I go on and do
something else so that's sort of how I
saw it I saw it almost as like instead
of going to grad school and going in
debt for grad school okay I'm gonna go
to grad school for YouTube and learn
everything and I and I did what were you
doing for them exactly so my technical
title was video producer so that really
meant everything yeah sure so we would
have to conceptualize the videos film
them edit them and upload six a month
and what's the process like who comes up
with the ideas is this all on you and
you who you run the ideas by if that's
the case well again it's been it's been
quite a while since I've been there but
at the time we would you know have group
brainstorms we were kind of divided into
different teams there was a team for
like food videos or um IRL scripted
videos there was unscripted so we sort
of brainstorm as a team think at
Greenland and then you'd go off and
shoot and edit everything speaking of
have another one guy did the food did
like the the most expensive food the
least yeah what happened are they still
doing that
um so he
and Lim
um Ryan and Shane were the guys from
BuzzFeed unsolved they left and started
their own YouTube channel called Watcher
are they not doing that format anymore
because it was so good I love it when
they're in the car and the guys in the
back yeah the audio thing is like
tinkering I missed those videos really
special
um I don't think they're doing that
exact series anymore because they're not
at BuzzFeed and I'm assuming it's owned
by them but they do kind of similar
content sure got it and when did you
decide to leave I decided to leave in
2017.
and I kind of got to this point where
a lot of creators that are probably the
most famous creators they're like Quinta
the try guys Etc they were sort of moved
into this really cool Department called
the development department develop they
all got these special contracts and I
sort of reached this point where I was
like I could either stay here and wait
for the opportunity to be given a
contract or I could leave and like
really bet on myself and see if I can do
it and own the whole thing process yeah
so I I really took a risk but I just put
in my two weeks and I was like I've got
to do something for me because again
like being you know a first generation
immigrant
um my dad moved here with nothing I felt
like my whole life I'd sort of done
stuff that followed a specific path
whether it was like get a good SAT score
go to a good college do this do this and
I was like you know what I want to try
carving my own and if it fails then we
all come back and work here okay were
you making videos on the side already or
were you just a buzzfeed you had some
savings and decided to make the leap so
I would say like six to 12 months before
I left I decided to move into to a small
studio apartment cut down all of my
expenses I stopped doing like literally
everything I pulled the gram stuff and
lifestyle full totality that's great
thanks gram happy get your duplex Prius
all right
um not even a Prius like a really like
10 year old car invest in watches okay
oh no it's that Ford GT isn't it that's
so bad
um and I I did that because I wanted to
train myself to be comfortable with
failure yeah if I go out and do
something entrepreneurial and I make no
money doing it I'm gonna have to be
comfortable with this lifestyle and so I
decided why not get comfortable there so
everything else is a fun surprise every
form of success is a surprise
um yeah but thankfully the channel did
well was it right off the bat was it
like an instant success like what was
the first video you posted so the first
so I did a why I left Buzzfeed video
because everybody did right
um it does pop off right they did yeah
yeah and I think a lot of people look at
those videos and like oh it's like a way
to get tea or drama for views or
whatever and I was like you know what I
think people are just going to click on
this video because of the title so I
instead of sit down talk to camera about
my experience because I was like nobody
actually cares I decided to make it a
Marvel trailer so I hired a bunch of
people who were like in the Marvel stunt
team to craft this fight scene and it
was meant to be like a trailer for my
channel so it's kind of a fun bait and
switch surprise sure but when I posted
that video I got a couple hundred
thousand subscribers now again when
other people have BuzzFeed they've grown
a million followers in a week that was
not me and so from there I had just had
steady grind you know like grinding out
videos pushing myself because again like
I didn't have an established show like
the try guys or anything when I was
there I really kind of developed that on
my own trial and error after my time
there listeners we all know YouTube
could be a great way to they consume a
lot of great free content but as a
Creator it becomes difficult to monetize
it could often be very inconsistent well
thankfully today's sponsor you screen is
an easy to use membership platform that
allows creators with large or small
followings to get paid the way you want
to you screen creators are from a
variety of Industries and backgrounds
from Fitness education music Financial
courses or anyone that wants to make
money from their video content and
create their own Community the main
benefits with view screen is that it has
everything all in one place you screen
handles all of the video hosting live
streaming payments billing marketing Etc
so all you have to worry about is making
the best content possible you also get
access to powerful website themes
designed to monetize videos they also
allow you to build your own mobile and
TV apps so that your viewers can watch
your content anywhere at any time it's
quick to set up it's fully customizable
and no coding skills are required it's
perfect for people like video creators
instructors coaches influencers and
entrepreneurs looking to build a
predictable Revenue stream from their
videos so if you're a content creator
and you want to have reliable
month-to-month income check out use
screen with that link Down Below in the
description again the link is down below
in the description to get started today
and now let's get back to the podcast
I'm curious when you put in your two
weeks do they not try to fight for you
to keep you around because I still feel
like although you maybe didn't you
didn't have like a dedicated show you're
still kind of a staple thank you uh
uh I
you know I had I had some meetings when
I was there before I left
Lee I I stayed firm in my wants and they
were not
at the time I think seeing the value in
keeping me on in that capacity again
because I wasn't like a try guy or
anything like that and other people had
left
um
and I was just really firm in what I
wanted in the level oh wow you're good
you're good
that's terrifying oh my God
I think I was just really firm in what I
wanted and honestly like the things that
I wanted I could have only gotten doing
myself having full ownership of the show
having complete creative control you can
really only get that when you totally
own something end to end so even if they
had come back with like oh we'll pay you
this much or this that or the other I
don't think I would have gotten the
actual value I wanted until I actually
had left which is why you know you see
so many people have left even regardless
of whatever contract they had how long
was it until you stumbled upon the
current format of your your channel it
probably took me a year of trial and
error on my own YouTube channel before
we really developed what people know
today as challenge accepted and what was
the first one you did the first one that
I did technically I I did a video where
I trained like a Victoria's Secret model
for five weeks and I found this guy
named Steve who is like in Culver City
and he's trained multiple of the
Victoria's Secret runway models and you
know back then in like when he's 18 I
guess that was sort of a Hot Topic is
like how are these women actually
preparing for this runway show I'm
someone who is very short so I would
never get hired by Victoria's Secret
anyways but I thought what would happen
if I you know as a normal person would
push myself to do something like this
following the diet following everything
and just see what happens and um the
video ended up doing really well and so
I I found myself at this Crux like you
have these difficult decisions where you
can do what's easy like you could do a
video that takes a day to produce or you
could do something that takes a really
long time to produce and bet on it you
know like I don't know when I put up a
video that I've spent six months of time
filming if it's going to do
astronomically well but I will know that
it's a great product and that video
really challenged me to do that yeah oh
my God we spent five weeks training for
this three weeks editing put it up God
knows how it will do and thankfully it
did well so it really encouraged me to
just put my head down and really commit
fully to every single video I make what
was that process like can you walk us
through what it was like training and
like what was the most surprising from
that
so again I was working with Steve Zim
who's a fantastic trainer I pretty much
just show up at like six or seven every
day work out there for two hours go home
there was a very specific meal plan that
I followed and from there it was just
rinse and repeat and I would say with
any challenge whether it's Fitness or
otherwise the first week is really
exciting because it's oh my gosh I have
a new lifestyle I'm really committed I
feel a lot of um excitement about it
it's a whole mind and body shift and I
find that in every single video I do it
doesn't matter if it's training like
Victoria's Secret model training like a
chess Grand Master every single video I
do where I have to commit to something
for an extended period of time it's a
complete like Metamorphosis
have any of this habits stuck with you
let's say that the two hours of working
out in the morning and egg whites like I
bet if I do that for a few months I just
stick with it I just continue that now
it's really easy to stick to it when you
have a video or like a specific goal in
mind but the time period after like once
you put up the video is this very
bizarre like no man's land and someone I
know another Creator actually did a
video recently where they like did a
body transformation for five weeks and
he texted me he's like is it normal to
feel completely directionless after the
video goes up and I was like yes
completely normal
um but I find unless unless I have a
video or like a very specific goal it
doesn't
work for me like it doesn't become like
a full habit shift now obviously aspects
of things like from my military videos
for example anytime I've worked with the
military or a you know a distinct
government organization I reaffirm that
appreciation for waking up early and
like every minute of every day can be
effectively used
um but I don't fully like I haven't like
fully changed my life necessarily from
one it's kind of like picking and
pulling the things that I love the most
about each what would you say was your
least favorite to train for chess really
why is that do you just not like chess
what was the hardest it was the hardest
there were lots of things I loved about
Chess and so many great people who tried
to help me out learn chess when I did it
um but chess was absolutely the most
difficult
um because it was fully mental Challenge
and
I like I was a pretty academic person
growing up like I was I loved math and
but and I thought okay I like math chess
chess is math right is it is it math I
don't you still don't know
obviously aspects of Chess are math yeah
but
it's definitely a different muscle
Beyond Academia or physical ability I
don't even know how to describe it but
it literally drove me crazy because it
was in the pandemic so I couldn't film a
lot of the normal stuff I I usually film
and people had requested chess for a
while so I decided I gave myself this
arbitrary goal of a thousand which is
like a ranking within chess I said okay
I'm gonna try and get a thousand and one
of the chess coaches I was working with
another YouTuber Gotham chess he's like
okay you can get there in a month maybe
three months it took me eight months
this video is eight months of footage of
me just pouring my heart and soul over a
freaking chessboard losing my mind in
the pandemic like I was going through so
many arcs like the world was shutting
down I was like stuck inside my brain
but that was chess is I I admit to feed
to chess I feel like what about Chess
like what was the most
difficult part about that because I know
it's all strategy and like if this piece
goes here it's just a game of like logic
right or do you have to it's like Logics
a lot of it's memorization is it yeah
some you have to know your opponent and
like they're more likely to play
aggressive and therefore I have to like
build around exactly there's there's a
lot of knowing the opponent studying
their opening versus yours adjusting
your defense against their opening like
the permutations of Chess are just
literally infinite and it kind of drove
me crazy just a little but I think that
it it bothered it was tough for me to
sit with myself in every other challenge
there's a physical component I'm moving
through something I understand that pain
as an athlete um but for some reason
chess because I couldn't
there wasn't like a meditation to it for
me like there is my body physically no
that makes sense to your point you
wanted to give up on that one oh my God
four months
instantly I mean I I think there was
even a segment of time where I was like
I gotta take a week off I can't you know
I I had to take time away I had to come
back
um it was like wrestling this it's like
wrestling a snake or something but that
was crazy but yeah I I definitely wanted
to give up there are a lot of times in
my videos I want to give up even the
marathon video that you saw recently I'm
like do I really need to run 30 miles
can you explain that to the viewers who
have not seen that video yeah so
um I I my most recent upload is a video
where I ran a marathon in the hottest
place on Earth kind of to celebrate my
30th birthday I guess weird weird
birthday celebration and I wanted to do
it because
I felt like it just sounded like a crazy
thing to do who would run a marathon in
the hottest place on Earth and it turns
out as I learned there is a group of
people who do this every summer it's
called the badwater 135 they won a 135
miles hottest place on Earth in Death
Valley
um which so they're actually the true
heroes of this but I thought you know
what I want to challenge myself to
really wring out the end of my 20s and
push myself to that next level and just
see what happens to my body and mind you
know what can be achieved
pushing myself to this limit so I
trained for four weeks I had four weeks
to prepare how long don't do that
because the most we've learned before
that I have done a marathon previously
but it'd been a few years and it wasn't
in the hottest place on Earth got it
okay yeah so for uh for training for a
marathon of this nature you go out do
your run come home and immediately get
in a sauna no water intentional what no
water and you sit there for like 30
minutes just sweating and honestly
what's the point that to acclimate to
the Heat
because even though we're here in Los
Angeles where it's quite warm during the
summer it doesn't compare
to Death Valley so wow yeah how
challenging was that
is that like pretty challenging that was
was that like harder than the average
challenge or not as hard it was it was
more difficult than the average
challenge I would say I mean all of them
are incredibly hard I mean okay listen I
this is gonna sound crazy I would rather
run a marathon than do eight months of
Chess ever again oh wait what is it
about this chest Valley put my ass back
there and run a marathon in Death Valley
just like strongly dislike chess now no
I love yeah when's the last time you
played chess casually
um the last game I played was literally
the game where I crossed a thousand are
you kidding so you're just done you play
Alex botes oh she's great yeah she
actually helped coach me really yeah
okay
yeah is that if you do a match with her
I mean I would lose very promptly but
chess boxing so she can handle the chess
and I can that's a good idea he is doing
yeah isn't that so cool yeah yeah are
you you're not participating in that I
am I am not um that would actually be
something to participate in yeah yeah
that would be interesting are there are
there any ideas that you've just
automatically just said no to that you
just don't want to do or maybe is too
dangerous or like it's just there are
ones that I have said hard no to and
then they find their way in I end up
doing them the marathon is one of them
um training like a professional gamer
was one that I did so I trained with
like a professional fortnite team back
like a couple years ago when fortnite
was a bit more popular that one I was
like I don't is anyone gonna care about
this video because I am not a person who
grew up with video games
so I didn't know too much about it now
obviously I understand now just like
again
being a professional gamer is another
thing that I just have even more respect
for but probably the one I was most
skeptical of was so I went to fire
academy for like training to be a
firefighter and as a part of the trading
they they're like we're gonna put you in
a burning building now is this a
simulated burning building no real fire
was it a real actual fire that they'd
not like did not like a real purposely
not like uh no it was a my apologies it
was a training structure but the whole
thing's lit on fire god yeah I thought
it's like hey there's a burning house
you run in there and we'll be there in
like three not quite I only had a few
days of training but when they said that
I was going to do that I was like are
you actually serious that y'all are
gonna put me in a suit and
have me go in there not just sit in
there and experience what it's like to
be in a burning structure but there was
a challenge involved they had a
mannequin in there and then I like a
certain amount of time for me to get in
drag the hose in
spray it down and save the body before
it was too late I was like are y'all
actually serious here like I am going in
this burning building and um you know
obviously I'm I'm glad that I was
surrounded by incredible professionals
to help guide me safely through all of
that but you've just gotten to do some
really crazy once in a lifetime stuff
now one video I found very interesting
is the 911 oh thank you come up with
that idea well actually what's
interesting about that video is so it's
the same organization that we did the
firefighting episode with so I did at
South Metro Fire Rescue in Colorado
they're amazing they actually have their
own YouTube channel where they show day
in the life of being a firefighter being
a paramedic the firefighter video we had
a fantastic experience with them we went
back and I did a video where I went on a
24-hour paramedic shift with them and
while we were there I was just thinking
this is obviously what we're
experiencing is crazy but could you
imagine being the person who's answering
the phone for victim and then while on
the phone with a victim calling out the
paramedics and the firefighters and
everything yeah so I was just kind of
curious and honestly it's sort of like
at the end of
2021 when we started thinking about this
idea pandemic was still a little Hit or
Miss in terms of filming ability and we
thought okay if we do 9-1-1 dispatch
that's a bit more contained and honestly
I didn't know how I was going to perform
I was like are people gonna care if I'm
sitting at a desk answering the phone
and obviously there's way more drama
involved than that but I truly thought
you know when we put up the episode I
was like
we'll see how it does yeah and I did not
expect the reaction at all because I
think we all take for granted the
ability to call 9-1-1 like if you passed
out right now we can call a phone number
and someone will come at some point and
that is such a privilege and and these
people sit at a desk just waiting for
those calls and waiting
to receive someone on the worst day of
their life and the mental trauma and the
chaos I wanted to better understand all
of that yeah I don't think I could do
that I would get too wrapped up and too
emotional and like the calls and I've
heard some of these 911 calls on Tick
Tock it seems like I knew yeah those are
a new thing right now is posting those
calls on Tick Tock yeah like you know
um voice not the voiceovers but like
showing some b-roll and stuff like that
and I'm amazed at their ability to say
so calm and unemotional throughout the
call oh my God and just and just like
they're like this has happened this time
okay uh so is you know is anyone injured
oh what's the injury okay where are you
like like stuff like that but they're
not affected I'd be like oh man are you
okay
I wouldn't laugh but I'm just like I
would no of course not but I'm just
saying I I would just be like you know I
wouldn't be able to understand I don't
think you could do that
and remain unemotional now I don't know
man I don't feel like I feel like you'd
be good at it you're very logical and no
my heart would be raised yeah I mean
when I did my fake call with an actor
yeah uh at the end of my episode I
didn't know what kind of call I was
going to get and I was so surprised like
why am I so emotionally impacted just
hearing an actor
talk to me about the birthing process
and they're having a baby in their home
and I'm the person guiding them through
that I mean I think I was just so
overwhelmed with the fact that like when
I was working there and taking this fake
baby call there were people in the
office who had actually done that
recently like oh yeah I've delivered
multiple babies over the phone
I was the person that parents were
calling during the stem shooting
it's incredible the the fact that these
people are able to
vocally remain calm well probably
mentally going through a billion
different hurdles is it's a different
type of Bravery to me so is it common
for 9 11 dispatch people to be like
constantly in therapy or in some sort I
was wondering what the mental health
component is very interesting and I
don't think every dispatch location
offers those Services thankfully South
Metro does have some Services of that
kind where they
um you know for any of their employees I
believe
who have experienced something
specifically traumatic how do they
become that like what's the process like
to go through that process and say I
want to answer calls for 9-1-1 it's a
pretty rigorous process so I got to
experience a little bit of it in my
video but there's like a a comprehension
computer test where it's almost like
it's it's sort of testing how quickly
you can move the mouse and give
directions over the phone those kinds of
things there's a typing test because
while you're on the phone you're also
typing to the paramedics what's going on
so you're listening and then going
through so that's a lot of the skills
and then of course an interview and
doing some of those mock calls like I
did to see how you actually perform
Under Pressure wow and what's your
process like now for picking a video and
like what what does that look like I
pick the topics honestly based on things
that I'm very curious about and people
will comment and ask for for specific
things but something we did this summer
was I actually went to the international
Butler Academy in Europe it's this
castle in the middle of the Netherlands
where they train the Butlers that go on
to serve like the royal family
presidents billionaires the profession
of bottling is one that I didn't even
know wait it's called bottling I think
that's the verb how do you know that it
still exists honestly I thought that was
gone like 100 years ago you've heard of
that Jack no no just being a butler oh
yeah isn't that crazy is that they still
do they call them Butlers I feel like
really no obviously some of the
graduates still go on to like
work at five star hotels or executive
Assistance or something like that yeah
or like Butler Service on cruises yeah
some of these people go on to work for
like private jet families like they
become a part of them what's training
like for that like why does someone need
to be trained to be a a butler the
training for Butler Academy is
fascinating I really can't wait for this
video to come out but
um It's a combination of like learning
the specifics on every form of etiquette
there was a three hour class I sat in on
T if it's a green tea it Steeps at this
temperature for this long and then you
remove this and it should be served with
honey not sugar like
there was a whole like chart like
diagrams for every form of etiquette one
of the tasks I have to do is set a table
did you know that there is a measurement
accurate way to set a table like as in
this many centimeters from the fork is
the is the is the spoon and the knife
and they measure that out with these
like measuring sticks they
and it has to be measured perfectly you
give me 45 minutes to do a play setting
and I failed why does it matter that's a
really good question
and I think that's something I ask in
like every episode or challenge that I
take on why does it why does it matter
or why would you want to do this what's
fascinating about the butler Academy is
I Look to these students in the eyes I'm
like why are you doing this what are you
doing this for and they all genuinely in
their heart wanted to serve they receive
like it's a it must be a unique Gene in
my opinion but they genuinely find their
life's purpose is to
help other people yeah and the the
measurement thing I was like I look
that's a little the instructor I was
like why why are we doing this because
when it's done correctly it's it's
almost an art form it just looks so
beautiful and I guess some clients at
dinner whatever you you know whoever
you're trying to impress those little
things that they might not even notice
that's what a butler is responsible for
it's the unspoken and unseen things that
make you feel good inside
I feel like if I had a butler I would
just become their friend and then they'd
just like be hanging out with me all the
time it wouldn't like they couldn't
really serve me anymore because like
yeah I feel bad asking them to do stuff
like that like hey this Fork is like a
centimeter off like I couldn't I I
wouldn't care right so there's so many
things that I would just let slides
that's not a big deal oh yeah that you
know that's fine I'd be probably too
easy I mean I I learned that I don't
think I'm cut out to be a butler but
having one would be great what is the
pay like let's say they graduate how
much do they make afterwards six figures
really oh my gosh
it's a 12-week program you graduate and
wait a second so you're saying someone
without a college degree could go
through a 12-week program make a hundred
side hustle right there add that to your
next video why aren't people doing this
because I'd much rather do that than
work like four years in college maybe
yeah going to debt for maybe you know 50
60 Grand right afterwards why aren't
more people doing that I think people
don't know what exists and now they will
because of my videos
I'm just saying it sounds too good to be
true a 12-week program like people are
going into the trades and like working
their way up is an oppress Apprentice
you know when they could just be a
butler I mean I'm sure it's so
competitive like only very competitive
10 and a lot of the people there had
prior Hospitality service experience of
some kind now not all of them have
college graduates college degrees I
should say by any means but they all had
like worked at a nice hotel in some
capacity they had experience before
coming here it wasn't well actually you
know now that I'm thinking about there
were a couple people who were 18 years
old just graduated high school
who were going to Butler Academy now
obviously getting a job afterwards yes
that's the difficult part but
the academy claims that many of their
students on average go on to figure this
out do they have to learn security too I
would imagine that's that should be part
of this like home security just it's
Security in general like if they're out
with their their employer and something
happens that they would have some sort
of security training in addition to yeah
I think they do that and I believe they
also do I didn't personally get to
experience this but they also learn some
self-defense
um how to deal with a guess that maybe
at a party that they think has stolen
something like very difficult social
situations that
I mean it's incredible what they can do
be like sir empty your pockets
you know what there's one if this
reminds me of something that I think
you'd be fantastic at there's that uh in
England what was it the nanny it was
like this I want to do a nanny School
episode I reached out to them but they
weren't available this summer but
Norland school yeah
yeah and that was the one where they
they make crazy income but they it but
for me it was the security aspect of it
like they have the stroller but they
have this thing where they could like
swap the stroller around take the kid
like shoot a gun with the other hand
it's like yeah what you have to protect
the kids at all costs yeah a nanny a
nanny yeah they're trained with like
Firearms like accuracy and like every
weapon you could imagine yeah secret
service agent it's not even but but they
say that the salaries are like a hundred
and fifty thousand dollars a year when
they get to these handles but they could
like seriously think of a good nanny a
wealthy person would easily pay 300
Grand a year yeah for someone that
travels with them who has security
training yeah um it's incredible and and
the interviews of the people who go
through that genuinely love kids and
they just want to do it exactly and it
makes a ton of money just like the
butler Academy I was like why why do you
want to do this
the genuine like they the one of the
instructors we met with he's said that
one of the greatest Joys was when he
felt that his boss had accepted him as
part of the family like that was for him
a life milestone is battling a nine to
five or is it like it's like a 24 7 type
situation I'm sure that you know in a
lot of like upper class households who
have this type of service there are
shifts or multiple Butlers
um but in a way you're you're the house
manager if something goes wrong with the
house or the family you're there it'd be
so hard to have a life outside of
battling like having a girlfriend or
boyfriend or I had a friend in high
school who had a live-in
Nanny since he was a kid like I think
since like you know he was born there
was always a living Nanny and she was a
part of the family I mean just like
she'd be at all the family events I mean
they embraced her as just like you know
as you would at like a brother or a
sister
yeah and I think she continued to live
in that even after he moved out because
she's just that a part of the household
and she's like she was in her like you
know 60s I think at that point but um
just it seems like a great relationship
he's really happy
I think it'd be cool to talk a little
bit about the business structure that
you have I've been waiting for this
question all right here we go I'm
curious about it too because it seems
the videos are so well produced thank
you I'd imagine there's there's more
than just like you and one person with a
camera let's guess the size of our team
I'm gonna say I'm gonna say they're
probably
two to three full-time people and then
three to five halftime
part-time do you have a guess yeah no no
no I want to guess you probably have
two people for for
camera work I would say two people for
editing and then one person for like
management and so I'm gonna say five
okay so we have in addition to myself
three full-time employees so you're
perfect on right on there and then we
have like
probably 10 different Freelancers that
come in and out for filming whatever we
do an episode like Marathon that was a
crew of 13 people wow yeah yeah that's
incredible yeah so so walk us through
like walk us through first like your
average day like an average work day
what is that well what does that process
look like just okay in general okay so
like yeah I got it okay so
my day is very completely based on what
I'm training for but typically the way
it goes is I'll wake up early I will go
and get my training done first so for
example earlier this year I did a video
where I trained like an Olympic boxer
for 100 days so I would go super early
in the morning train come home shower
and then the rest of the day I spend
producing so I would say that my
strongest skill set is in organization
and Google Calendar email management
like me and Carissa do a lot of all of
that crazy planning so when we shoot
with the FBI when we shoot with Secret
Service it's me on those calls it's me
picking the crew and making schedules
and everything so I I get like a weird
sadistic
joy out of that time that's pretty much
what I spend the majority of my day
doing in the afternoon I'll do some sort
of recovery like an ice bath so I'll do
an ice bath
um cook dinner
what about and do it all over again but
this is coupled with like
um you know in a couple weeks we're
gonna fly out and shoot a video so I'll
be gone for a week but then I'm also
while we're on set waking up early
taking calls training for the other
projects while I'm training for
something else at any given time I'm
probably training for two to three
different projects at once but to kind
of answer your thing about like what's a
day like
um like a year or two ago there was one
day where in the morning I went and I
piloted a fighter jet for NASA training
and in the afternoon I went to ballet
class
for training like a ballerina for six
weeks so it it's really exciting which
is fun so what's today so today today
was
um
today we had a team meeting with our
editors we're working on bringing on
another editor right now which is really
exciting we're also hiring so if you
wanna you wanna pull a Jack and just
slide into my DMs and tell me how you
can help me that'd be great there you go
we're available and excited to have you
yeah so we were doing that and then
Carissa actually our assistant producer
she's part-time Singapore part-time La
okay so she came in last night so we
were doing some stuff with her and and
you were like let's do a podcast so we
cleared off the afternoon thank you
let's do it perfect do you have an
office or do you work from home that was
an interesting thing I was excited to
talk to you about because you're the
real estate person
um so in the pandemic we entertain the
idea of an office or renting commercial
real estate and when we did the math I
was like we're gonna pay so much money
for a rental on Commercial Real Estate
so what we ended up doing
was we found a house that has a guest
house so we re-outfitted the guest house
to be our production office and then we
live in the main house it's a very smart
idea that's what we had oh my God yeah
you did something right this time
oh my God you're gonna be like you're
doing no no yeah you should be moving to
Vegas that's what we did here though
Jack was in the guest house uh and then
I was here and then we have the office
here and some other like you know we use
this for filming but it worked out
really well I love it I love it because
we don't have to drive anywhere to go
into work or whatever and it just saves
so much time because I found that the
most valuable resource is my time
because I have to use so much of it for
training for being in the car for
whatever that every minute matters and
the the less time I can waste even if
it's just walking to the backyard to
have a conversation with our team versus
driving 10 minutes at every minute
matters yeah I think even yesterday we
did a podcast with Patty Galloway which
is fantastic he's really good I spent
more time in the car driving down there
than we did actually filming a podcast
wow yeah but you went to the wrong Hotel
no it was 50 minutes to go from here to
Marina del Rey it doesn't make any sense
Lincoln Boulevard oh yeah yeah exactly
during rush hour traffic Patty was great
but it was 50 minutes down there and
then I got to the wrong Hotel so Jack
just tells me he's at the Hyatt I didn't
know man there are three Hyatt hotels on
Century Boulevard oh three there's like
the higher Regency the Hyatt Place and
there's like another Hyatt I show up to
the Hyatt Regency and Jackson's room 170
uh or 1207 and so I go up to 12 or so
I'm knocking on the door and I hear the
shower going and so I called Jack I'm
like hey no you know the shower's
running he's like no Humphrey's there uh
he'll let you in I'm thinking maybe
Humphrey's is in the shower so I just
wait you went to the wrong Hotel
stranger's room yeah so but I hear the
shower keep going and then I'm just like
I'm still not talking you're not getting
it but I hear the shower going and then
I call Jack back give me Humphrey's
number like call Humphrey then he says
oh let me open the door for you
in the shower opens it up he's like
you're not here got the wrong Hotel I
packed everything up went to the right
hotel now you have a great story now I
have a great story so that's that person
was taking a shower and they're knocking
I'm curious like if they open I'd be
like hey I'm here for Jack I don't know
oh my gosh yeah oh and the only reason I
got up to the room by the way was
someone else went to the 17th floor and
used their key card oh my God yeah
that was the only reason it's just
you're a good sport about it though that
was fine but yeah no I think I think
that uh that time aspect is extremely
important yeah do you know how much it
how much it costs to make your average
video yeah so our average videos these
days are anywhere from twenty to thirty
thousand dollars wow yeah and how often
are you posting once a month oh my gosh
that is more than I thought did you do
this math prior to coming on or do you
just know just well I figured you guys
were gonna ask me yeah I just know it
already wow does that make you nervous
in case the video gets demonetized or it
doesn't perform or are you pretty
confident that uh so the way that
kind of our business the way that our
business is working currently is
obviously we have AdSense and brand
deals are awesome and then we also have
a fitness app that we run so there's
kind of an expectation of a certain
level of income per month and so we
allocate it in various ways across the
different projects but typically for
some of the bigger episodes like the
marathon for example we're not going to
do unless we have a sponsor involved and
it's of a certain
pay structure yeah so do you figure this
out ahead of time like you have this
video idea you go to the sponsor
negotiate and say we'll get you this
video in three months so for the
marathon video it was a really amazing
opportunity we partnered with Brooks for
that so we actually made like a full
outline with like pictures and you know
temp vo and everything and we pitched it
to them and they were really into it
thankfully and they offered to not only
pay for the episode and you know like a
brand deal rate but also they provided
us professional athletes to be in the
episode they came out they supported me
it was a really cool partnership so I'm
always looking for those like bigger
more tentpole situations because we have
so few videos to choose from you know 12
to 15 a year probably
um that I am pretty strict on who we
work with and how it's going to work and
when it's coming you should do a day on
Wall Street please
if you did that with like a good spawn
answer like public.com gram you would be
I that video would do so well if you
rang the bell on Wall Street I don't
know how you could do that I'm sure
somebody watching this podcast would be
able to make but now I want to do that
too I don't want that idea yeah
I'll produce the video so you don't have
to worry about it yeah honestly if you
get that opportunity I'd love this to
show I would love to show up and do that
okay because one of the things I want to
talk to you about today was I want to do
a finance episode because I just think
it'd be obviously you know the benefit
of everybody having more education
equity on finance and
I don't know what we would do but that
sounds awesome I would love to do that
have you ever seen Mike Shake oh he's
great yeah he did like uh I learned how
to day trade and that video did pretty
well for him okay and that might be kind
of interesting like learning how to day
trade in 30 days you just lose
everything yeah so what would I do on
Wall Street because a lot of people from
my college I mean I even interviewed for
Wall Street stuff and I don't even know
what they do yeah I interviewed and I
don't even know what I would have been
doing I I mean my first thought is
you're gonna get someone who's on the
Wall Street uh uh Wall Street floor or
the the trading floor and you're gonna
watch them go back and forth with their
papers and yelling on the phone and like
doing what they do pressing buttons and
stuff like that oh my God I don't know I
don't know what really they do
you're the finest yes I don't know
like everything I do is from I don't
think that they I think it's digital now
right yeah
it's like oh I lost my dreams
yeah but I'm sure you could find
somebody there who's like busy who could
walk you through the average day I've
heard that they're very strict on
filming
so like a lot of the times they don't
want any filming done so I'm sure maybe
you'd be able to get like an exception
through that like if it goes through I I
have no questions yes jets are someone
watching has a connection with Wall
Street who could maybe put us through to
make that happen but I could have to do
that okay I'm gonna work on making it
happen I will let you know how would
they let you know how okay Michelle
carre plus business gmail.com just email
me if you can do it just email me let's
go back to your income are you
comfortable talking about that good sure
if if a video costs thirty thousand
dollars to make what's the ROI on that
oh my God
so we so like I was mentioning too early
we have three
three different buckets of where we get
income from AdSense is one and now
because of how the videos have been
performing this year we have kind of a
standard of where that will be
brand deals we only accept over like
high level at this point like we don't
really do a 60 second shout out or like
a random website or anything it has to
be like a pretty big opportunity and
then the fitness app which is a
subscription service so even if a video
doesn't make
30 grand back in AdSense by itself
typically we can get that back with
the app or like plugging the app and
having people go to it like in the
marathon video we also launched a run a
10K challenge which other thing we spent
today doing and basically in the app you
can get all of my workouts which are
actually the workouts I do in the videos
so kind of measure it in a variety of
different ways if that makes sense
what's the app could you walk us through
this yeah yeah so the app is called MK
fit and it's actually a white label app
so I work with another company who kind
of runs all the customer service and
backend and everything but I was really
really excited about this opportunity
because instead of selling like PDFs or
like here's my nutrition guide
downloadable thing it's actually
replayable videos of me doing hundreds
of exercises so when you open the
workout you actually see me
demonstrating the exercise how many reps
everything you can fill it out in in the
app itself and it also has recipe guides
you can DM me personally so like for
literally two hours today we were
responding to people who were in the
middle of the the 10K challenge yes it's
actually us responding it's actually me
yeah I I love that because I love
actually working with people one-on-one
yeah
um that that to me is where I find the
most value yeah that's true fiance
involved in the business as well yeah so
he's the creative director how do you
mean him I met him uh working on my
YouTube channel actually yeah so when I
left my job I wanted to work with a
director because I was previously at the
job like you know being on camera
directing myself editing everything and
I just wanted like an external pair of
eyes to kind of be on the lookout for
story specifically so Garrett has like a
really strong background in traditional
filmmaking so he's done multiple docs
he's won a bunch of film festival words
for narrative too so I brought him on to
kind of help with that and
he is so good at it he's just amazing
and but how did that start from like the
professional aspect to then now there's
like a romantic element to it I mean we
were strictly a professional friendship
for like a year
and who made the because they're most
curious like who made that correct one
I'm just curious yeah I do I want to
like how do you how do you break I'm
just curious yeah right so
it's a really long very long story it's
too long for this podcast okay
um but yeah I mean Garrett Garrett
basically
I don't know how many can say about this
okay I keep looking at Carissa
scandalous it's not scandalous it's just
long to explain but yeah
Garrett basically approached me
a very romantic way and that I have to
tell you something that could either
be amazing or ruin our relationship
and he you know proceeded to tell me how
he felt and I was like oh my God
obviously this makes so much sense and
so we sort of just like leapt into it
head first and I was so nervous because
everyone tells you don't work with your
spouse don't do this don't do whatever
and we really approached it in this
really cool way where we like made Rules
of Engagement almost like kind of like a
business prenup if you will kind of
thing and once we laid everything out it
just allowed us to be fully creative
with one another and it was so cool
um so I I really value the relationship
we have like we're really good with each
other about our working hours these are
relationship hours and just the energy
that Garrett brings I I know that you
probably know from experience both of
you that trying to find a partner is one
thing both romantically and
business-wise but finding someone who
brings the same level of enthusiasm to
what you're doing is like a diamond in
the rough how do you shut that off
though and be like all right it's 6 p.m
we're gonna shift from like work mode
now to like you know partner mode oh my
gosh now we're in like relationship
couples yeah I'm just curious yeah so
for us what we do is if it's past a
certain time we ask permission like hey
I have this work thing on my mind I have
this really cool idea can I talk to you
about it and the other person can say
nah I really just want to watch Survivor
and go to sleep right now can we talk
about it in the morning and sometimes
it's hard you know when one person's
really excited about one specific thing
and the other isn't but most of the time
we end up talking about it sure
absolutely we have kind of like this
language that we approach when it's not
working hours so sometimes permission is
denied yeah absolutely absolutely how do
you separate that because it for me it
bleed like work bleeds into everything
and so for me if it's like hey got a 10
out of 10 today I'm in a bad mood oh
absolutely it's like how does how do you
shut that off or like well then you guys
get in an argument if like like a
business disagreement like how does that
not carry forward when you're watching
Survivor let's just say oh well I mean
of course like the energy of who we are
as people carries over in the same way
if we worked two office jobs and came
home and both had bad days it would
impact the relationship so it's it's the
same thing as that and obviously if
something really needs to be talked
about we talk about it and it does bring
us closer in our relationship which is
really cool but yeah to answer your
question we definitely are like nah I
just want to watch Game of Thrones House
of the Dragon we can talk about it
tomorrow we'll like put it in calendar
and then talk about it then that's
interesting so when he approached you
were you all in as soon as you mentioned
that or did it take you some time to
think well let me think this through a
little time and then I was like you know
what I just let's just try it cares once
we laid everything out too
um you know further into the
relationship it it just allows so much
freedom I encourage anyone who's in a
romantic relationship that involves
business as well like lay it out what
happens if this doesn't work out what
happens if we move out who keeps what
like we literally made a spreadsheet of
when we move in together I own this you
own that we co-own this I would keep it
I stay here you leave like yeah sure
whatever it is and thankfully you know
that is something that that has so far
had a zero Roi on doing and it's been a
great investment at the same time take
that time and have that
perceptively difficult conversation but
like it leads to a lot of relationship
intimacy too because you feel so much
Freedom like there's nothing like
lingering or like well I'm kind of like
stuck on this one little thing but I'm
scared to talk about it no having that
open all-out discussion has been
I mean really set the tone I mean we did
that like in the first month that's
great and when did you get engaged we
got engaged a week before the pandemic
and we're getting married in two weeks
oh my congratulations congratulations
when is that gonna be when yeah all
right sorry sir where
um Malibu wow that is awesome now can we
ask how much you're gonna spend on the
wedding yeah
more than 60 Grand I mean it's pretty
yeah
oh my gosh how much are you planning on
spending on your wedding so I pricing
this out with me there's there's one
spot that Macy looked at I think it was
like 30 grand just for the venue I don't
know uh it was like in L.A yeah it knows
oh hi I think that's gonna be so pretty
yeah but it was like 30 again plus
everything else and then all in it's
gonna be like probably 50 or 60. there's
another spot she wants me to see on
Sunday that I think the venue is like
10K But it includes some other stuff and
they're just now starting to do uh
weddings so they're like you'd be one of
the first so I think they want to give
us a break on that yeah what about some
sort of promotion or something like that
what do you mean like sponsors leave
strategically yeah are you making
content around it we are making content
so like we did a video um that will be
coming out where we plan the entire
wedding in a week videos we plan our
wedding in a week
Atlanta in a week and get it over with
and also make contact honestly if you
have the ability to take a week off of
work and just say
this is the week we do it I highly
encourage literally everybody to do it
because there's no like oh it's after
work and we gotta like look at flowers
and I'm tired like you just bang it out
we lined up every single vendor meeting
we were like those chairs this this this
dress it was do they agree in advance to
be in the video like they know they're
okay
that's very cool yeah and so that pays
for the wedding I mean so whatever cost
probably is what you spend you're gonna
get it back probably on the video right
well hopefully I mean we'll see if
everybody here watches that video then
maybe that's will pay it back do you
find a sponsor for it but this wedding
the New Aura ring that would be
fantastic you know a lot of the
businesses featured in the video our
local business is so you know sometimes
we work out like okay I'll post on
Instagram and we'll get a discount or
whatever
um but in terms of a title sponsor
you're working on that but even if we
don't get that that's okay because to me
I think I think it's going to be a great
video so that's kind of how I measure
value which is probably very different
from Mr Graham Stefan yeah I don't know
I've joked about having sponsors in the
past be like uh you know get public it
gives everyone at the wedding a free
stock
just you know stuff like that doesn't
invite me like hey like under under your
chair right now is a free stock one of
you guys gets uh Oprah stuff one of you
guys gets Berkshire Hathaway
feeling like it happens yeah
energetically as someone who's
incredibly Frugal yeah about spending on
a wedding why not a Lopez
Santa Barbara part of me wants to do
that
um but I think there's an aspect to that
where like family wants to be involved
and
um what are you doing it for family or
for you I think well to have a bigger
wedding would be for family if it were
for me I'd probably have more fun just
picking a random night like with no
planning at all and just be like hey but
but you know what we want to do it on
um I don't want to say the exact date we
want to do it on the day that we met
like that same day so we're kind of
limited to like it's got to be that
specific day
um but part of me also just be like it
would be fun just to be like hey what
are you doing tonight all right let's do
it do you live in Vegas so I know but
but there is something else so special
about having that exact day
so I think we're leaning towards that
exact day but then I think it also makes
sense for people that want to be a part
of it yeah something that Garrett has
helped me understand is just like
there's this concept that the people I
think they like interviewed a bunch of
people who were um like on their
deathbed about regrets and and whatnot
and people have said that the people who
have the most number of Novel life
experiences throughout their lifetime
feel like their life is longer
so for example if you work a day job and
just kind of doing the same thing every
single day your life will feel much
shorter than someone who is investing in
tentpole memory experiences so
maybe your life will be a little bit
longer from having a blowout wedding
maybe
no I'm just trying to think usually like
it feels longer when you're doing the
more repetitive thing because it seems
like the day just like drags sure yeah
versus when you're doing new experiences
like a week will go by really fast sure
so I'm thinking hey you're not gonna
feel as long look back and remember much
stuff if it's the same thing every day
but it feels longer Graham's gonna at
the end of Graham's obviously like I
lived like what am I 30 and he's like
90. that's what's gonna happen
I don't know can you say approximately
or assign percentages to like wearing
yeah absolutely yeah so I would say that
probably
like a large portion probably 70 of my
income is from sponsorships in those
like big tenpole types of sponsorships
then it would be I guess 15 AdSense and
then 15 percent
got it how do you balance between such a
rigorous schedule and like a personal
life
[Laughter]
um it's difficult but I'm fortunate that
a lot of the activities that I do for
videos are things that I would be
curious about in my own real life and my
own Hobbies but it does make it
difficult because sometimes I have to
remind myself when I'm going to the gym
to work out that's not personal time
it's technically working time and
sometimes it catches up to me yeah but I
mean it's it's definitely difficult but
I I feel like as I've gotten more
episodes under my belt and just more
time in the YouTube world I've found a
better balance in general and I know
when to say no and stop where do you
want to take it from here because it
seems like you've got a great format
that's working and how do you expand on
that well my big goal right now is I
want to get nominated for an Emmy for
challenge accepted so I would love to be
a YouTuber who gets nominated for an
enemy which other YouTubers have done
with the help of other production
companies but I want to see if I can do
it myself
and that's why I've invested so much
into
quality of the episodes themselves why
we don't upload as frequently because
I'm very particular on the quality of
the content itself and just developing
myself as a producer who can produce not
just on YouTube but in other formats as
well for television I've had some
experience hosting on traditional TV and
I loved that so I'd love to kind of grow
as a as a performer
um you know whether it's like being a
Marvel TV show would be really cool or
hosting an adventure show would be
amazing to do again I would also think
that there are a lot of ideas that we
have about expanding my business in
terms of product whether it's Fitness or
Fitness adjacent or lifestyle based
stuff I can't do much about it but
that's kind of where I see the business
going next is working with like ideally
I'd love to find a company that is
making a product kind of in their early
stages and see if I can attach with them
and work towards it got it together now
to be nominated for an Emmy where does
the content need to be posted no
um Johnny Harris who is a YouTuber
produced an amazing piece for the New
York Times and he literally won an Emmy
this week like what was on stage
accepting it can anybody be nominated
or does it have to be a certain format
like can someone nominate me like hey
guys nominate me for an Emmy on my video
with Mr Beast like without even qualify
if enough people I I think they're you
know there are a lot of like different
facets of the Emmy so like there's the
front facing Prime Time Emmys which we
see on TV then there's the daytime Emmys
which are for soap operas Law and Order
Etc so it depends on how you spin it if
you wanted to qualify as like you know
challenge accepted could technically be
like short form documentary it could
long form like it depends you kind of
have to like work with uh with someone
who's applied previously or like a PR
agency to figure out where you
that would be interesting to get one of
the interviews as like you know an Emmy
nominated I'm not gonna lie I don't even
know what the Emmy like is that things
are basically the Oscars for TV I
thought that was Golden Glow the Golden
Globes
expands it Golden Globes is these and TV
it's very confusing oh okay but it's
just different agencies
give out Awards and we should get an
Emmy
grahamas this podcast will get an Emmy I
want to be a New York Times bestseller
at some point I think that would be a
fantastic one it's not like not that
challenging yeah well so it's 10 000
physical copies have to be sold I
believe within a certain time frame
um if you sold each copy for like two
bucks in the bottom all yourself
I don't know I don't know if you can do
that that would be an amazing video you
make yourself a New York Times
bestseller like no one bought it except
you I bought my own yeah you're the only
owner of it but people did that for the
for the Shopify stuff was it Shopify or
um
oh gosh click funnels
they'd get the awards but they would buy
their own stuff please I know a few
people
I made myself a New York Times
bestseller yeah but I wouldn't want to
buy my own copies like because that
feels like just cheating and I I don't
think there's no way that that could be
well you're doing it for the concert
yeah it's not like you actually want to
be an authority no but the thing is you
if I don't want to be serious about it
you know who Alex fasulo is okay so
she's like this girl that ghost writes
thing on Five Ghost rides things on
Fiverr basically is she on Tick Tock yes
yeah okay okay and Graham wanted her to
to write a book for Graham to be a what
is it a New York Times bestseller seller
no no it was a joke for Ramsay Ramsay
but you wanted that to be in New York
Times bestseller right for Ramsay yes
that was your goal that's it yes wait I
have a question is it units 10 000 units
or ten thousand like of does it have to
be a certain price
I don't know can you just make a book
that's like one dollar sell it in
Burnside but I feel like it then that's
a hack that anybody could use is to call
them signs call themselves in here
that's why it's a great video yeah you
gotta exploit that other people I feel
like other people would have done it you
don't do this I'm gonna do this yeah I'm
gonna make myself a New York Times
Festival I feel like it then everyone
would do it and then it wouldn't work
that's why I think nobody's done it I'm
pretty sure they have I I think it's an
exploit that people already are aware of
and like there's got to be something
else there's no YouTube video on it yet
or right or it's got to be sold
throughout like a certain amount of
stores like it's not like someone could
like buy ten thousand cops for a dollar
each and like spend 50 Grand yeah unless
I wouldn't want to be a New York Times
bestseller by like cheating okay okay I
actually want to do it seriously yeah
I'll get that yeah
but I would like to do that now I want
to be a an Emmy award-winning video yeah
yeah the right heart and soul yeah I
would do that what's something you think
you're doing poorly that you should work
on and do better at oh this is such a
good question
I think
what I would like to get better at
myself is I feel comfortable in the
entrepreneurial phase of like
I feel totally comfortable cold emailing
the FBI and pitching them on a video and
making it happen I feel really
comfortable on the entrepreneurial side
of my life when it comes to content
itself or the Avenues that I currently
have within the business but when it
comes to like like I was mentioning to
you earlier finding a company in its
infancy working with them and becoming
their CMO and kind of like
marketing the product as my own in that
capacity
I find it as is is very is is a lot more
difficult to find those right
Partnerships so I think for me it would
be expanding in product I think it'd be
good for you to associate a little bit
more with the finance space and if
that's something you want to look into
like the hormuzis and the jungkookens
really because they're all trying to do
stuff that are similar to that yeah
by finding company I'm available
I don't know I like that I like the
challenge concept I think you could take
that to 10 million subscribers oh yeah I
mean if if truly if I had it my own way
and all I had to do was make content
that's what I would do that's where my
heart is absolutely yeah and I feel
fortunate that like
some people grow their YouTube channel
on one format and they're like I have to
keep
one-upping it or it has to be bigger and
higher quality and I feel like we've
kind of found a certain threshold for
that with what we have already and I
just want to keep doing that I mean if I
had a my way you know we're bringing on
another editor hopefully we can increase
to two uploads a month that in and of
itself will do so much for our channel
in terms of viewership brand
opportunities Etc but if I had it my way
I would just do the show that's all I
want to do yeah I think you could do
that I think you should also be doing
shorts yes yes I have I've heard a lot
about shorts I went to the YouTube
Creator Summit and the whole time they
were like shorts short shorts they were
really pushing it and now you can
monetize them uh 2023 yes so yeah in a
few months yeah I'm I'm shocked with
shorts we've been posting shorts in the
iced coffee hour it's driven so much
growth but but monetarily I'm curious
where that will go like when we activate
it what is the CPM on a short how does
it change based on viewership or length
like my understanding is that it's going
to be based on a percentage they're
going to have like a total fund and then
you get a percentage of that I bet it's
going to be higher than Tick Tock but
yeah probably not going to be that right
like that's why there's so many views
like yes we can make money off of it but
what
what does that actually look like and
can someone truly just be a shorts
Creator people can be long form only and
have really probably not an AdSense it's
probably going to be a lot like YouTube
during the adpocalypse where people are
not making money on videos but they're
making money on Affiliates and
sponsorships that's probably how it's
going to be for sure it's it won't make
any money on the short yeah it'll make
money maybe doing a sponsored short
every now and then yeah I mean I I I'm
curious to see where that will go and
truthfully I haven't done much with
shorts just because I've been so focused
on long form and our videos take so much
Manpower just to get one long form out
but the
shorts I'm curious what yeah I bet if
you hired one person full time just done
shorts you would double your audience in
a year just for taking your existing
videos translate over to the Longs now
it's beginning to okay so that's what
scared me because I am familiar with a
few other very big YouTube channels once
they started posting shorts you get like
no views on the long I've found the
opposite I was really worried about that
too and we started testing on the iced
coffee hour posting shorts and those
shorts are getting millions of views and
it's beginning to translate over to the
long form content never thought and so
then I started testing on the main
Channel and it's you're seeing some
conversion overall the videos are doing
better because I think YouTube is now
recognizing that people who want shorts
a higher percentage of them would be
interested in the long form content they
rolled out that feature yeah it wasn't
that way previously right then they just
changed that so I'm guessing that
probably will but yeah your best hire
would be one person shorts full-time pay
them really well to make sure they know
shorts and just take every video you've
made so far and turn that down into 45
seconds it would do so well I agree
you would double your audience and do
that you should
I'd say that would that should be your
priority is it you editing who has no we
got this guy Josh Josh who's um who's
editing our shorts right now and we're
tweaking a little bit just to optimize
them so he is full-time he has multiple
clients want another client probably or
are you trying to hire him full-time I
don't wanna I don't know
yeah oh my God we're gonna fight over
John no I'm sure I'm sure I'm sure yeah
okay I mean yeah I'm gonna use contact
yeah because I
I've had trouble with the short stuff
finding someone who can take the story
and narrow it down they have to be
really good and I've started just like
I'm obsessive over the long form content
like from the algorithm standpoint I
started really spending so much time on
shorts and so he'll send me a short and
I'll watch it when come back with notes
on top of already his stuff and I'm
getting really into it and I think
there's there's it's so much different
than just taking a video clipping it up
and like reposting it right but there's
so much success with both like we did a
week where like we had our editor we're
like you're only gonna do shorts he he
took a video and boiled it down into the
one minute and it's it took a few like a
while to get it there but it did well
and then we've also had some success
with like taking
specific scenes and just making them
vertical what questions do you have for
us
or is there anything else you wanted to
talk about of that I want to talk yeah
I'm I'm just having fun I'm so excited
to meet you both cool what would you
change about what I'm doing like
financially how much are you saving and
investing how much am I saving and
investing
saving and I'm investing like very
conservatively like how much is like
what percentage of your income would you
say saving probably
because I put so much back into the
business probably like
20 we could get that up
a little bit yeah do you have expensive
taste in anything are you no you're not
spending money like Scottish people
stuff yeah that's a nice jacket that's a
nice jacket I didn't buy it how much is
a jacket where's that this jacket is an
expensive jacket really
who's the designer who's uh who's the
mighty company the what the mighty
company the mighty company I've never
heard that before how much would it be
this is a thousand dollar jacket but I
got it as a jacket I got it as a gift
who gave it to you Garrett
for my birthday
it's a nice jacket because I saw you had
something similar for Colin Samir yeah
it's the same company
but I'll I get that was okay it's a good
joke as well good jacket yeah good job
anyway so I don't besides this jacket I
guess I don't like have
like I feel like a lot of influencers
they get money they're like I'm gonna
buy a product purse I'm gonna yeah do
this I'm gonna buy I don't even know
like a lot of that stuff I don't
I don't yeah everything goes back into
my business I mean that's fair and your
channel is growing so it's not like
you're putting money in this business
it's just like not doing well I think
that's fine I mean I'd always just say
like maybe 25 like you could just push
it up a little bit where are you
investing in where am I investing yeah
in like mutual funds do you know which
ones or what they track
I work with a business manager and I
pretty much just tell her like put it in
somewhere safe business manager yeah
it's kind of interesting do you know how
much they like charge for that service
for that service that's like part flat
is it flat fee or a percentage what's
the percentage uh not of the investment
of
um just like total revenue
wow yeah
that's it what's the what's the purpose
of that like what does that serve for
you in terms of having a business
manager so because I'm not really at the
point where I need like a full-time
accountant internally but they handle
like everything so they do taxes they do
payroll they do invest in like if a
credit card gets stolen they fix it and
whatever you know like it's very I get
that it's really nice because we have so
many Freelancers coming in and out yeah
and they do all the paperwork they
handle everything they make sure
a good service to have
um you do that all yourself yeah
yeah it's a mess it is it is horrible
your finances are a mess
um
kind of it's sloppy I I just because
there's a lot of things where I think
that you need bookkeeping I do I mean I
I do it myself but there are some things
where I'll get invoices and just like
I'll
keep a Word document on my computer word
not even Google doc no oh my God type it
in and I'm you know I keep track of
payments why not Excel like this doesn't
even make any sense I don't know how to
use Excel
I've just been doing it this way since
the very beginning okay and I just like
you know I have a credit card I use for
one thing a credit card I use for
another thing and like my expenses are
there yeah and then like two bank
accounts three bank accounts yeah right
and then at the end of the year I could
look through these let's just call them
six accounts in total and then tally up
where the money went I mean there's
always a record of like money went from
this account over here and then I could
check over here and do okay that person
was paid x amount but
I'm sure it could be better I'm sure so
you don't use
um like rap book or stir or any program
like will you stir we used it anymore
what happened to them what happened to
them we just well we I don't think we
actually yeah we received payments
through store but that was it like the
people that were paying us changes yeah
there's just there's just like a lot of
money coming in and then it too much too
much money coming in yeah it's such a
big problem and an octopus is you know
everywhere else and uh but I mean I I I
track everything so like I know where
it's going but if you enjoy it but it's
sometimes uh when it comes to tax time
and like Gathering all of that it's I
just book out one day
count it
yeah with you yeah I take one day I
don't do my taxes now but in terms of uh
tracking everything before like usually
the beginning of the year I'll take one
Saturday and from the start to the end
I'll just coordinate everything and just
go through every account track every
penny that goes in and out where it's
going and then I reward myself at the
end of the day with sushi and like
that's the one thing I look forward to
like I'm not finishing until it takes me
a full day so but I would say it's like
10 hours that day and it's not awful
because I know which accounts the money
goes in and out of yeah I mean I would
much rather have
someone hourly or like full time just
I'd probably be doing that I should I
mean not you can obviously do whatever
yeah I should yeah I should probably do
that I should probably have a better
understanding on stuff and I think like
this year specifically we've just been
growing so
quickly that like just getting videos
out has been such a priority and sitting
back and being like where is stuff going
financially is something I want to get
better at yeah a lot of it too is I I
have a big interest in taxes so
sometimes I'll be reading up on stuff
and then I'll pass it by a tax attorney
say hey I just saw this like what do you
think of this and I'll either like say
that's a good idea or it's too risky
don't do that or here's why it doesn't
apply to you but I'll do a lot of
research on on just random stuff that I
see coming up and I like passing it by
like bouncing ideas off of like a tax
professional it's called it's way too
complicated should not be that
complicated and you prefer this over
hiring a bookkeeper I should hire a
bookkeeper I think Grant would prefer to
hire a bookkeeper but Graham doesn't
like having many like employees or
anything expenses yeah I mean it's
probably a worthwhile expense but I like
just I know when I do it I I track
everything and I have it but they could
do that for me too but I like just
seeing it and then doing the tracking
they would do a better job than me I get
that though
it's I've done it this way for so long
that I it's like it's working but are
you gonna continue doing it for the next
10. do you feel like it's inhibiting
your growth no no I don't no it's one
Saturday I mean like when you think of a
weekend how much time most people waste
it's nothing one day out of maybe the
month or the year out of the Year oh no
I mean oh throughout the month I mean a
concert every day check the bank account
all this like just see what's going in
and out like I I look at it but one day
there's just so much money coming in
yeah
it just keeps going I just keep
refreshing and like the number keeps
growing
do you
want
are you laughing
yeah then it just can't zeros out yeah
it's the same it's the same for me and I
hate it like even yeah I do one day
every single year right before the taxes
you do the same things I hate it dude
and you know you know you don't like it
that much you really it's incredible but
I feel so great after I get it done once
it's over it's good but yeah the one
thing though I've uh because Alex now
has a business credit card that's under
me and so once every other month I'll
look through the credit card for like
expenses and I'll be like oh Alex what's
this he's like oh we did this for the
podcast let's put this oh we did this
I'm sure there's a better way to to
track that but uh but yeah but that
would require like someone
I was about to say something Joe what
did you say you were you were saying you
did that too oh I do that too just one
day and I go through like I don't even
know how many expenses probably like
over a thousand transactions and I I
have to remember like what did I do in
February that's really not good to
publicly say yeah but yes this is this
is what I was going to mention is that
uh this year is the first full year I've
paid
um my estimated taxes usually I prefer
to pay the penalty I'll pay the full
amount at the end of the year so
whatever I would owe for that year I
just pay it all one lump sum and I've
taken the penalty usually I think it's
like three percent and typically in the
past I've I've Justified that I'd rather
pay three percent and have access to my
money liquid to invest it and the
Investments would make me more than what
I would get
um why not why is it different this year
um this year I realized I've been
holding on to too much cash and so I
figured I'd rather just instead of
there's way too much money so I started
but no no but my whole point was not to
make it
I've never because I I have not been
investing all of it and so at the end of
the year like it made sense when I was
at the point where I'd be investing
everything and then I would find a way
to pay the tax like just enough would
come in and I could pay the tax
afterwards but I'd be investing all of
it and really up until like three years
ago every year around like November I
spent all the money because I'd be
investing all of it
um and then it was last year where I had
extras left over where I was like I
should have just paid this off instead
of paying the penalty because I'm not
earning any interest on it and now that
just cost me money okay so but it's a
great feeling now I'm now I've actually
overpaid on taxes so I'll get your taxes
so I'll get a refund nice I'm really
looking forward to that yeah yeah I've
never I've never I would have thought
you could only underpace since there's
just so much money yeah
no I've overpaid because you're supposed
to pay like 110 of your prior years tax
or like up to and uh yeah I did that I
finally get a refund
I paid a lot but I'm hoping that I get
some money back I don't know yet no yeah
yeah get solar
yeah I should I also found out
apparently my accountant forgot to close
out my California thing when I moved to
Las Vegas so I had like five grand for
that even though I didn't live in
California at all last year for a single
day but I have to pay California still
and I live in Las Vegas wait wait
explain what happened so apparently like
I didn't there's like some form that you
have to file if you leave California to
announce that you've left even though I
was in Las Vegas for the entirety of
last year I still have to pay it's about
five grand
because you kept the because like I
didn't close I think it was my yeah my S
Corp like I didn't close it until like
the next year although I did open the
other one then I don't know it's
something it's something weird I don't
really understand it we'll just take
some of his return yeah
be nice yeah so are you paid
in an S corp yeah through okay
interesting
yeah yeah good business structure it is
Jack's happy with it I'm happy with it
I hope so what other questions you have
okay so I asked what do you think I'm
doing wrong what can I do oh sorry to go
back to your Investments okay
um mutual funds I'm sure I'm not on here
because I'm a finance person I want to
make that super cool like index function
until I work on Wall Street for a day I
would I would say it probably I'd like
to see which mutual funds it is like how
you're invested but I'd say most likely
if it's a mutual fund you're already
Diversified yeah uh as long as you're
not like in bond mutual funds right now
which have like really declined in price
as long as you're not in in those I'd
say you're probably fine I'm guessing
it's just like a diversified Index Fund
basically which is good uh 20 is not bad
I I would just up it a little bit if
you're able to but I would say it's not
but you're also telling me I need to
hire a full-time shorts editor yes but
that wouldn't be safe I think I don't
think it'd be that bad because you're
going to get an Roi from the shorts like
like I think the reality it's hard for
me to see when it's not monetary well
the realistic scenarios yeah the shorts
would probably break even so let's say
you pay somebody like 70 grand a year or
like 60 grand for just shorts uh which
actually might be pie if you're only
posting like one a week like one really
good short a week let's even say like 50
Grand you'll make that money back from
the people that convert to the long form
content the app that you have or even if
you do one or two sponsored a year will
pay for that person entirely also just
like the Creator fun Tick Tock although
it is very small when you couple that
with the Instagram reels bonuses oh and
Facebook actually yeah and Facebook oh
you'll make money it actually you could
actually profit so there are a couple of
months this year that's the same content
everywhere yeah everywhere there were a
couple of months this year that we
actually made money accounting for the
amount that we pay our ticket
interesting yeah just from The Tick Tock
income yeah like yeah and also Snapchat
discover you can try to get like a
Snapchat discover time I have a Snapchat
thing okay I don't
you don't use it did it discover you
would know if it's discover it's uh yeah
it's like we have a show like they said
yeah yeah accepted yeah and how often
are you posting on that once a week I
think it's once a week yeah they're
going through the whole back catalog
cool that's are you doing Facebook yeah
yeah I am doing Facebook how often do
you post on there once a week also I
believe yeah I would say for the shorts
because you could double that throughout
everything so Instagram Facebook reels
um Snapchat you could figure out
something on that I would say you'll
make your money back so that's not an
expense it'll break even or you'll make
money on it
Okay so
that's what I would do but yeah I the
income I'm sure sounds fine
sounds fine sounds fine it's not too
much it's not too much but he's not too
much cash not too much cash yeah oh my
God what's something you think we're
doing bad or poorly I should say how
could we that we can get better yeah or
you could hire a bookkeeper yeah 100 I
agree with that yeah that's fair I get
that hmm well tell me like so obviously
you guys advise me on the finance what
about content how are you feeling about
the content you're creating and making
lately good because there's finally
stuff going on in the market it was a
rough last
four months for me it's odd when the
market is going up people lose interest
in investing when it's going down
everyone is now interesting yeah so it's
amazing that I see the difference on
views every day the market closes up
versus down if the Market's down a
percent views usually increase by like
10 to 20 if the Market's up user down
it's crazy so in a way it's it's almost
as a hedge against my investments
because if my investments are going down
I make more but if my investments are
going up I make less so it's kind of
like on YouTube balances yeah it really
balances out but there's more for me to
talk about when the Market's going down
because more is happening and more
people are interested yeah because
they're like what just happened what did
Jerome Powell just say how does this
affect me
um and I think for a lot of people I
think it's just human nature we're more
impacted by losing money than making so
if I told you like you could either make
100 or lose a hundred you'd fear more
than losing 100 than making so
um so there's more interest in investing
but I've been pivoting a little bit to
these interviews that I've really
enjoyed and my goal is to get like two a
month
do you need to hire a producer no no no
no I have three in the pipeline right
now
um that I but I don't want to post them
like back to back so I'm like I want to
post one wait because this is going on
the main this is the main Channel yeah
yeah yeah
um but there's a I've started creating a
list of people that I want to meet and
interview in that sort of style and so
I'm just kind of working my way through
the list
yeah but there's like 20 people on the
list that I really want to go through
yeah and are you feeling fulfilled and
excited by what you're doing by that yes
because I think that's such a cool style
and it just opens up the audience is
finance I think there's um
you know there's a limit to how many
people are interested in finance and
growing beyond that is really
challenging
um because then you get in the
maintenance phase where like so you know
some people are dropping off while new
people are coming on and I think there's
that that natural cycle over time when
you get into interviews then you you tap
into people who are interested in the
finance of creators or just
extraordinary people in general doesn't
have to be creators yeah
I mean I feel like what you guys are
doing definitely works in terms of like
the level of fulfillment you have on the
main Channel as well as the podcast how
do you feel about your relationship do
you view uh I always feel like I'm I'm
tough on Jack I feel like sometimes
because I'm always a job you should like
I'm so on it all the time 24 7 where I
think I had that unrealistic expectation
for Jack to like we always got to be
working all the time uh you know always
pick up the phone call yeah permission
what do you mean again romantic asking
no
no we we have a I think we have a good
balance okay that that's what I that's
what I think and Jack has some great
ideas and I trust Jack's judgment on a
lot of things like if I come in with an
idea and Jack hates it like absolutely
against it I'll usually end up siding
with Jack unless I'm like a hundred
percent sure on the idea but Jack could
usually sway me either way we had a good
thing going when we were here we would
go for runs ah and we'd run down to the
park it's too hot in Vegas we just don't
live with each other oh okay yeah
but when we were here we'd run down the
park and uh this is kind of creepy but
where's this going it was it's a
children's park yeah but they had these
awesome like monkey bars and so with
awesome monkey bars they were not just
your average they were awesome you're
like two guys going there and then we do
pull-ups on the monkey bars but
sometimes their kids like playing on the
monkey bar so we like just wait around
until they stop using them then we go
over like do pull-ups yeah we just
didn't want to like interrupt the kids
or like or just like random guys yeah so
she needs their space yeah yeah but I
would say that's honestly that's the
main thing I've realized that
communication obviously like everyone
knows this in the back of their mind but
they need to be constantly reminded of
it or at least me is that communication
is key you always need to be talking be
open with the other person and uh I
think that's something grandma and I
always need to work on for sure
um but overall yeah obviously he's one
of my best friends like very satisfied
yeah do you guys enjoy Vegas yes it's
it's interesting because when I'm there
I don't want to leave and I want to get
here I kind of feel mixed because we're
rarely ever here and sometimes we'll
just be here for a weekend but then when
it's here it's like wow it's so nice
with the weather and like all the
greenery I miss that it always takes me
a day to get used to it back in Vegas
but so I like it when I'm in Vegas and
then I also like it when I'm here
what about for you yeah I like Vegas
yeah I definitely like it a lot more
than I thought that I would but I think
a big part of that was me just
establishing a friend group so now since
I have like my core friend group it's
very very easy
hang out get work done my house is a
great culture as well so that's also it
makes it nice as well yeah what are
y'all most intimidated by
with your current content or business
um timid I would say for the podcast I
would say
it's intimidating to see what because I
watch all the other podcasts too and I
see the guests that they have come on
some of them I'm like when I see Nel
getting on Elon Musk I'm like
where do we go from there like how could
we ever compete with Elon Musk hitting
on a podcast
um so some of that I'm probably a little
bit too hard on myself for that when I
see that yeah when I see his milk is
able to pull like such incred like to
have the president on their podcast I'm
like well they did it first but you know
it I have to remember that you know
we're not
you know this is the same as them
at least right now I don't feel very
intimidated honestly with the podcast at
all at least I don't know how I would
just yeah describe being intimidated
seeing someone else doing well I'm like
oh that that opens up a lot of doors
just for podcasting in general yeah that
is true
how about you with your work
oh I think yeah I think I'm I think I'm
intimidated in terms of
just like the growth overall
um and like hiring new people and making
sure that they fit and have the same
Mission and Vibe I mean it's it's taken
us so long to find another editor
because for us it's not like just edit
the video it's very involved in the
edits and I'm also intimidated by the
prospect of expanding into other
businesses because I feel so
at home with the content itself but
investing in other things in general
kind of freaks me out do you worry
that's going to take time away from the
video so you're not going to make as
good of a video if your time is split I
don't worry about that because I will
stay up as late as I need to make sure
the video is good it's more just like
investing in something that might fail
yeah well I think even if it does fail
the loss is not going to be that much
yeah I mean in the big picture and
you'll be able to probably get a video
out of it even if you do fail true which
creators do you watch on YouTube
so I the creators I feel like I look up
to a lot and learn a lot from and watch
a lot of are Ryan Trahan Iraq Max fosh
you guys oh my God I know like I know
that name but I yeah I've probably seen
a couple of videos Max flash is someone
I'm very inspired by lately so he is a
comedian who also does kind of like IRL
um challenge content but he does this
crazy stuff like he did a video where he
joined the royal family for a day so we
found a distant relative of the royal
family who literally signed a marriage
agreement with him and then for the day
he was like a part of the royal family
he's done that like his videos are are
are really impressive in terms of just
like the ideas themselves are really
funny and he's funny person
um and obviously Mike Shake is someone
yes who's kind of similar to my content
so I love him he's great and I think
Brian Trahan he's obviously the person
we're all talking about this year right
just someone who's done High spectacle
but maintained a grounded level of
himself throughout without it having to
be an extravagant spending of money for
it to be meaningful or even spectacle
yeah I think that's really hard I've
been watching his Vlog channel oh yeah
Channel where he's been watering his
grass yeah it's like how do you make a
video that's entertaining and I watch
them I was so invested in the grass I
look at that like how could I do
something like that can you water grass
and monetize it yeah yeah
um but Ian Ian did one save the
squirrels initiative that was great
um where he just traps squirrels you
make like a 15 minute video and just
like how to trap and release squirrels
but he made it so hilarious and
interesting and like here's how you make
the Trap and I'm gonna put it here like
report back the next day I love that
sort of content this is offbeat yeah I
appreciate it because it's
it's risky but with no risk like it's
risky to invest the time and energy to
create the content
um and make it like something different
from everybody else but they make it
seem so effortless like they just happen
to like turn on the camera I just happen
to be there and record but like I'm
looking at something look at some of
these like these shots that he's getting
are so good he's thinking this through
ahead of time it's not just off the fly
I bet some of this is at least Loosely
planned out
yeah so I want to be able to do that
yeah I'm appreciating this like this new
wave of almost return to grounded
personality because there was such a big
movement of like money money money money
and like
just wealth extravagance I think and now
it's it's sort of coming back to like
Casey neistat returning to YouTube I'm
sure everybody talked about all this
stuff I'm appreciating that almost like
homecoming that's happening yeah yeah I
think Ryan trans definitely LED that
um with that penny series and I'm
curious to see what he's gonna do next I
think he should just do another penny
series the same thing
like circumnavigate the globe yeah or or
giving a penny to Elon Musk I think
would be an interesting one or just pick
someone who's maybe unattainable and be
like I'm gonna
do that person or he did the trading and
penny to a house but maybe like do that
again would be interesting like give him
I think he's got to like go up a little
bit I think going around the world would
be really good yeah oh yeah navigate the
globe on a penny take me Ryan yeah how
fun that would be interesting I'm
curious with your
your different Avenues of content
creation and the products surrounding
them
what has been your biggest
Financial mistake full self-driving on
your Tesla oh
that's expensive yeah oh yeah yeah for a
YouTube video and immediately like
afterwards like you regret this so much
because it's like eight grand or
something it's 12 Grand now yeah he
wanted to make a video around because
all the other Tesla videos do super well
and he makes money but this one I think
the video just under yeah I've I've had
a really bad run every time I've spent
money for a video I've lost money
every single time the Pokemon card one
uh took two years to break even on that
but you did
yeah but I did break even after two
years now you're profitable but not no
okay so now I'm profitable
um you were the Pokemon card
um but yeah but that was a video where
like I had made three Tesla videos in
six months and all of them did one to
three million views and so I thought
well full self-driving would be
interesting I'm gonna buy it and then
review it and then it's it should make
its money back in ad revenue and it
didn't the video bombed
um I really think that happened though
probably bad title thumbnail I thought
it was an interesting video but I don't
really think people cared that much
about it and I probably just
miscalculated but uh you know the video
made two grand back so I'm I'm in the
whole six grand for full self-driving so
it could be worse but yeah look at that
and it was just like I spent so much
time on that video and and Jack was
helping me film at that time we're like
looking for locations to film and like
reverse into certain spots and I spent
so long on that video are you proud of
the product uh it's a good video but uh
but I judge those videos by like the ROI
I just everything has to have the ROI on
it that does not so that's where you
find pure satisfaction is just Roi so it
could be the worst video you've ever
made you could be like I don't think
that's my best and if it's a one out of
ten you're like kind of yeah because I
because that means the audience likes it
so I don't really make too many videos
for myself I think of what the audience
would want to see and so I gauge that
metric based on how many views it gets
what's the retention what's the the
overall sentiment about the video in
terms of like the comments and if people
like it or not so I make content for the
viewer
comes you whenever you get a 10 out of
10 and it's a bad day uh I've done
better about not taking it personally
because then I think to myself well it's
title thumbnail or I I misjudged how big
the audience is on this and some of them
I know are going to be tens out of tens
but long tail like I would say once a
month I post a video purposely like how
to invest a hundred dollars a day as an
exam sample I know my audience not going
to be interested in that but it picks up
a new audience
so over a year it'll do really well
because people are interested in that
but in the short term it doesn't so I
kind of term investment right
yeah but like passive income and side
hustle videos are the examples I say
this all the time I don't like making
them but people love watching them so
every six months I'll make a passive
income video or a side hustle video
because people enjoy it like an eat your
veggies video like you just gotta do you
just gotta do it um the audience enjoys
it there's an interest in that I don't
want to deprive them of those videos
just because I personally don't like it
like it's for me it's more about the
viewer and their enjoyment of it
so if they're happy with it then I'm
happy with it so I hope that answers it
well that's pretty good I mean if your
your biggest loss was 6K on a um on a
single video no I mean a bigger loss was
was probably not paying attention to
things that I should have been paying
attention to there were a few things
that I've done over the past like a year
where I should have been more involved
and I wasn't and because I was not as
involved as I should have been
um they didn't turn out as expected like
content adjacent content adjacent stuff
yeah but that I blame myself for because
I think well I should you know I've been
prioritizing all these other things if
I'm going to do something I really
should be fully involved and I can't be
as involved as I would need to while
maintaining everything else like
Something's Gotta Give I'm not willing
to sacrifice anything yeah exactly so
like you know and then you're in terms
of like your hierarchy of what is
important to you is content first then
and then the other yeah it's always main
Channel
podcast right below that second Channel
Vlog channels down there
um but the main channel has always been
the priority because that that's like
the top of the line funnel like people
come from the main Channel yeah didn't
go to the podcast it used to be main
Channel second Channel podcast but now
the podcast is is just doing way better
so I think main Channel podcast and we
have a lot of um overlap between the two
and for these other
board if you don't mind me asking was it
the partnership with the other people
involved or was it just like you've you
know I don't know if you felt this but
sometimes I feel like I've got to make a
product because everyone says I'm
supposed to and
or probably a combination of both what
is your advice in terms of
listening to that gut instinct
yeah for myself every time every time
I've gone against my gut because people
have told me oh this is a good idea you
should be doing this I've lost money and
I've been miserable and so I've stopped
and that's part of it because I've just
always had this this
air of like I I know what what's best I
know what I'm doing but other people are
telling me no you should do this and do
this and it makes like really trusted
people and I'm like maybe I should do
that that's a good idea but I don't
think it's for me and every time I've
done that even if it's not something I
really feel passionate about I've just
lost money it's taken away Focus I'm
stressed about it it's not worth it
that's how I felt about like even just
simple merch t-shirt hoodie whatever
because I feel that my audience is going
to expect a certain level of quality or
even that it's an athletic material or
whatever and
I don't know yeah I've struggled even
just simply doing that I've always found
that unless I'm able to give it a
hundred percent and like dedicate
everything to it it doesn't turn out as
it should it's not as good as it could
be if I was like really into it like I
have to be as obsessed as I am with the
main channel on something else and if
I'm not doing that then it's not going
to be as good thank you for coming on
the iced coffee yeah I appreciate it it
means a lot for you to spare this time
for us thank you guys for watching yeah
feel free to add me on Instagram JLS
Selby thank you so much and that's and
get your free stocks thank you Michelle
thank you is there anything you want to
shout out yeah you can um follow me at
Michelle Carrey on YouTube and
everywhere else cool beautiful all right
thanks guys
thank you thank you seriously for doing
this oh my God yeah